vamos tentar agora ninguém na minha mão
em trecho 21 vai na prisão pelos olhos
ou assim que a moça tem que fazer isso é
muito rápido a lei
pronto já tá muito estou ao lado de
pessoal aqui quem fala é dar que sejam
muito bem vindos a mais longa e mostrado
de que com mais um vídeo de microscópio
o futebol hoje nós vamos ver então
objeto objetos próximos anos muito ao
longo do dia
realmente russo incluindo uma coisa que
me dá um sentimento uma cervejinha sem
serem olha só eu e muitos ditadores as
respostas também tem medo várias
injeções que eu tenho olha só imagine
esta agulha quieta gol dentro da nossa
vai meu é muito superior muito hoje eu
vou citar esta seringa dentro da minha
pele observar isso com um microscópio e
vamos ver o que vai acontecer vai doer
mas também pessoal para tentar atingir
uma meta vamos tentar atingir os 26 mil
slides neste leyrielton isso em meu solo
e de 5.200 metros atingindo diretamente
o vulto de uma coisa ainda mais longa do
que disputar uma agulha no meu corpo vou
fazer coisas ainda mais além disso além
além de gostar de uma serra elétrica
dentro no pescoço não me deu a viagem
começará pelas metas nem por que ela foi
minha meta que não compreenda eu tenho
os meus vídeos entre outros vou ter que
fazer um tênis fogo ainda vou te fazer a
bola tocou na trave
ainda vou ter que ver um pássaro morto
microscópio eu tenho muito a meta ainda
primeiro não julguem pessoal não julga é
deus que isso nem eu esqueci vamos
tentar ver o esquecimento microscópios
olha só eu não sou aluna do primeiro
objeto então vai ser que alguém
provavelmente nós usamos mais uma escova
de dentes vocês já pararam para pensar
como escova de dente está cheio de
bactérias nerd mesma escova serve para
lavar os dentes
isso não tem mais mulheres a montarem
vocês lá vão dentro sujo com cuba e
odense bactérias quartas google é da
escola vai ter bactérias duvide da minha
campanha
o nuno gomes nela não se revelar um
bicho mil e dá um beijo eu acabo me eu
acabo vídeo digital na página logo logo
23 211 vai
qual o peso dos filamentos todos da
escova de dente o brutal ainda tem
restos de pasta ali foi um louco muito
logo a 1 pelo não não eu voltar à rotina
eu voltar aqui recordar que solo pelo
vai conquistar o mundo os poucos e
poucos ou pelo vai conquistar tudo
evolui dentro leandro ainda terrestres
basta que tão boas com água e painel é
bem linda minha escola né alegre bem um
herói
meu interesse é que eu encontrei aqui
muito pelo inter é parte da língua quer
coisa que ninguém usa nem ninguém usa o
que resta para trás olha só textura que
construí conep da brilhantina e em uma
pintada o pessoal que está aqui vai
também poder não é nada pessoal aqui no
caso tenha este do partido olha aí porém
também 5 em todas essas contas nem
planta caiu ação muito mais prazer na
escova né
é só mais como mas eu juro que pensei
que descobriu ter muito mais pelo e
sujidade que vem mas a opinião não é tão
limpa o próximo tem sido também uma
coisa que eu uso muito eu uso sempre o
mais diletos a legenda era olha só lá
meninas brincam muito afiado bolinhas
quilos bem estranho das bolinhas cair
vamos tentar aqui encontrar qualquer
coisa ruim e não me acho nem sempre
conseguem ver uma lâmina militar um
carro esportivo x1 de 2000 eu vou tentar
ver se em conta que há uma lâmina
partidas até agora nada ok vamos ver uma
menina a dona ok só separar em algumas
partes mais travadas aonde é que meu
estômago está muito estragada olha é
isso o que é estupro e laranja sol é
aquela parte que está na lâmina que
serve para hidratar o papel com nossas
passou na mina de pé para cima quero foi
tratar meu mas é bem estranha textura
expressa pular angel
isto porque eu acho que isso também seja
interessados no mas pensa função mil a
série está muito contato comigo eu acho
ela muito mais coisa para energia
elétrica quanto ao próximo potencial ea
próxima coisa partir uma toalha é suja
do banho e eu vou estar aqui e ver essa
textura da toalha vamos ver o que eu uso
o que poderá ser o sucessor tomei banho
estava limpo porque ela ficou suja mesmo
é um mistério é 1321 toalha surge do
bahia embora olha aí
uai vejam só meu tem muito pelo avaí
de cara já encontra o link pelo eu vi
perfeitamente tipo algodão da toalha as
fibras todas o asfalto pelo eu vou
tentar encontrar aqui uma parte surge da
medida que já tem que já tem e não se
conseguem ver mas tem uma mãe eu acho
que a copa não é que tá na gestão que
tem uma exposição de surgir a toalha e
1321 vai eu acho que está tudo aqui olha
aí fica mais escuro aqui tem muito mais
tempo do que em outras 30
só que aí encontrei a pior mancha de
todas só que já dá pra mim podem cair 32
mãe o que é isso eu acho que isso aqui é
mais fácil objeto vai ser um smartphone
samsung é o meu antigo e nós vamos ver
agora é o vidro partidos destes marson
mg só que dá para ver por dentro da
censura do vidro e viram que ela tem ou
até mesmo o bicho tem aqui dentro da
entrada usb ou tem muito lixo lembra lá
321 mais olha só o vídeo já tem aqui o
vídeo
eu vou tentar ficar um pouco mais e está
muito focado agora e olha sou leitura
bem estranho meu vidro partida muito
estranho cair você acabar com um zumbi
2000 mesmo muito fundo e ver se eu
consigo olhar por dentro da fissura do
vidro e dá pra ver perfeitamente fissura
meu colega sinto assim
é muito estranho ou ainda um perfil
muito aqui ok
ei olha só o lixo sul e meu aluno por
todo lado a cair vou tentar dar um zoom
e por exemplo só neste momento entrar
dentro do mar fone e já não faz mais um
gol da equipe
olha só olha só a quantidade do pop tem
que vencer muito bola e gastar porque a
entrada dos fóruns
só que muito pode também ele antes mas
parece um poço para outra equipe muito
bom explica que quando consegue som que
o peão vez dentro do buraco e eu não
consigo imaginar o olho além de um
monstro dentro do buraco eu vou tentar
quebrar a câmera do samsung ver o que
tem e willian e brutal meu pai de ponto
é o infinito nascimento essas músicas
não tem a luz do microscópio bairro vai
cair pra dentro da empresa também
talento é infinita porque fazer os pais
não acho que isso aí mas tem muito é
infinita lendo essa parte fora da câmara
que é o que supostamente faz um zumbi o
autofoco e não só no próximo objeto a
ser aquilo que eu tenho mais medo olha
só a liga não é muito grande essa agulha
é muito distinto do outro destaque
contudo da fifa
[Aplausos]
[Música]
agora só que ele também faz um desafio
do chão e lavar cuidar e e vamos lá
pessoal continuando vejam só esta agulha
meu é muito grande porque só chega então
guardamos uma vista macroscópico embora
seja 21 vai olhar agulha quem ou e sem
ponta olhei bem bicuda ok só não gostava
da minha mãe que é pra ser melhor né
olha só meu isto muito melhor aqui na
minha mão é um carro muito grosso assim
o microscópio
olha aí aponta muito bico do meu preço
uma lança uma arma mesmo olha aí poder
muito afiada o pessoal agora eu vou
fazer respeitar a agulha na minha mão e
vão vir tudo no microscópio ao vivo
embora lá sua luz que está agora ninguém
na minha mão em 321 vai
vejam só pessoa está presa na pélvis não
só o furacão que fez a agulha pessoal
também é justificada pelo o que acontece
em um lugar um pouco de 40 por mais pra
dentro da seringa estar dentro da pele o
que acontece
será que ela vai ficar completamente
pintada por dentro não sai mais um
centavo e agora vou tentar sugar aqui um
pouco do 40 eo pagamento gosta mas vamos
tentar ser feliz não vai atender o
corante do corrente parece mesmo sangue
olha aí olha só como ficou meu irmão é
um pessoal a segunda etapa e construiu
só tenham gostado e já sabem quem tem
mais coisas porque não que houvesse um
microscópio
muita gente ainda pergunta data porque
não vejo a iguana e tortuga do antigo
hino no microscópio volta deles sofrem
para o próximo vídeo talvez mas quem tem
mais coisas para observar que já estavam
só vamos tentar atingir a meta dos 200
mil leques neste vídeo e não esquentam a
15 mil padres vão ter dois filhos que
também podem ver é grátis entre 21
pontos e ainda tem muito mesmo e aqui
embaixo vocês podem se inscrever aqui no
canal do dac dos frangos é jay pessoal
fique bem e até a próxima